Monsieur le Commissaire chers collègues
oui c'était une bonne idée de faire de
2022 l'Année européenne de la jeunesse
j'ai défendu cette idée quand elle a été
présentée par la Présidente vanderlion
nous étions en plein covid les jeunes
avaient souffert lourdement de du
confinement dans leur vie quotidienne
cela a bouleversé leur quotidien oui
c'était une bonne idée mais on ne peut
pas s'arrêter là alors oui la il y a eu
des progrès l'implication des jeunes à
progresser mais nous n'avons abouti à
rien de concret et ça c'est le pire en
politique les promesses n'ont tenues de
celles qui font les abstentionnistes qui
font que les citoyens se détournent de
nous nous avons demandé par exemple de
respecter les engagements sur la
conférence de l'avenir de l'Europe en
consultant les jeunes sur les grandes
politiques qui les concernent et qu'il
est touche nous attendions cette annonce
lors du discours sur l'état de l'Union
dure sur la Fender la hyène mais il
n'est pas venu nous avons demandé
d'engager un cadre européen pour des
stages de qualité et justement rémunérés
nous avons aussi demandé un cadre pour
la santé mentale des jeunes rien de
concret n'a été annoncée alors je suis
particulièrement fière avec mon groupe
win you et mes collègues dragospice la
roue d'avoir mis en place un groupe de
travail qui met les jeunes au cœur de la
consultation politique et de nos
réflexions nous avançons ensemble mais
au plan de l'Union européenne le travail
reste à aboutir c'est pour cela que
l'année européenne de la Genèse doit se
poursuivre encore 6 mois et c'est ce que
nous demandons dans cette résolution
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]